spot of blood spider blood radioactive
spot of blood spider-man spider-man
we're gonna watch cosmic wonder news
secret spider-man movie revealed new
Avenger question marks all caps let's
watch this video right now by the way
follow us our good step 32nd reviews for
Phil's TV shows and or trailers posting
so damn often it's free to download free
to use you can use it too hey it's all
in the description box would love it if
you did in let's go into this follow us
first how's it going everybody it's
Warren welcome back to my channel the
cosmic wonder where we talk about
everything Marvel and I knew rockstars
yet are not warned by the way about our
friendly neighbors right battery and
what so many plans on doing with that
character and other characters involved
in Sony spider-verse or as they're
calling it now they're spider-man
universe of characters or Sony Pictures
universe of the Marvel characters just
based off a net name it certainly seems
that they have a lot of plans for
spider-man and other characters that
come from the spider-man universe boom
Morbius Kraven the hunter etc all of
which are dire man part of the MCU over
into the MC like we saw in the Morbius
trailer the picture of spider-man on the
wall that said murderer over and then
vulture showing up at the end as well
and it seems like Sony has even more
plans for a spin-off spider-man film and
more so we have some news about the
current project so we'll break it all
down in this video but first if you're
new be sure to subscribe so you can stay
up to date on all things Marvel and so
you can enter this week's giveaway for a
chance to win a black widow Funko pop
all you got to do is subscribe like the
video and leave a comment down below so
Sony has recently booked a release date
for an untitled Sony / Marvel film dated
for October in 2021 I take a fighter man
universe movie now of course since the
announcement of this speculation Jessica
Parker and there have been plenty of
movies that have been rumored to be in
development at Sony Kraven the hunter
Madame web Spider Woman
well now thanks to a few recent reports
it seems like we know what this movie is
going to be here's what a report from
variety had to say for writer and TV
director SJ Clarkson has son
to develop the first female centric
movie from Sony's catalogue of Marvel
characters while it's unconformity at
the center will be insiders say there is
a strong possibility that the film will
be based on the madam web comic book
character however recently insiders have
reported that this is most likely going
to be a Spider Woman film but just to
query right now is confirmed that Sony
is planning on developing a Spider Woman
film and a Madame web film as well I see
which one's better some people thought
they were the same but they are
confirmed to be different and thanks to
a new recent report we have more
information about the development of the
Spider Woman film according to Charles
Murphy from Murphy's multiverse dots
idle moments an interesting character
Matt Spider Woman film is well underway
Sony has hired executive palak Patel to
oversee the development of the film and
they've also hired Rachel O'Connor to
oversee the project as well and Amy
Pascal to produce it Amy Pascal produced
the recent spider-man movies as well
spider-man homecoming and spider-man far
from home now in regards to the story
for Spider Woman Charles Murphy has
revealed that it is in fact going to be
Jessica drew yes this is very dark
character woman Jessica drew eventually
goes on to become a new Avenger and then
she also goes on to join the Secret Wars
event and The Secret Wars event is most
likely the next Avengers in-game level
event that we're going to get in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe character
Spider Woman in the MCU much like they
do with the regular Tom Hollands
spider-man there's another important
thing about Spider Woman and the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and that is Hydra
originally a woman Jessica drew thought
she was an actual spider a spider that
evolved into a human but as it turned
out Hydra implanted fake memories of
cutting a spider into her mind and
there's been rumors recently what Hydra
could be reappearing in the MCU
so right now at this moment we have
discovered the secret project that Sony
and Marvel are working on together and
it's looking like they may just put
Spider Woman in the MCU to join the New
Avengers and eventually go on to be in
the Secret Wars event
so let me know what you think about this
news and would you be excited for a
Spider Woman film and do you want her to
be a part of the MCU let me know what
you think in the comments down below
saying character describes you can stay
up to date on everything relating to
marvel for live updates you can follow
me on Twitter and as always thank you
all so much for watching
look it's got parental problems too hey
I was dealing with parental abandonment
you know whoo that's a big theme in the
more they seemed in a lot of compañera
courser let's get it with Spider Woman
now yeah I'm not the most familiar with
Spider Woman unlike John who is an
expert at Spider Woman I've got a tattoo
and it's all about Spider Woman hey I'm
not the most familiar with her but
whenever I did originally he learn about
her I did find her backstory to be quite
intriguing because she's dealt a lot
with being program being brainwash being
manipulated powers given to her usually
done by some type of experiments I
believe she had an origin and then they
read it or orage and changed somewhat
like how she got the powers per se one
was like an experiment from her parents
or her dad more specifically and then
another one happened while her mother
was pregnant with her I think would be
cool to explore that especially in
contrast with a Peter Parker or a [ __ ]
Alice type of spider-man those guys are
like they're in their origin they're in
high school and they get bitten by
radioactive bug and yada yada yada work
with her backstory it ties into Hydra
and then eventually does become part of
the Avengers but there's something more
brooding about her backstory something
that's a lot more dark and I feel more
complex maybe not as relatable as a
Miles Morales or a Peter Parker but you
know it's kind of got a a bit of like a
Wolverine edge to it and you have a
Winter Soldier edge to it yeah all the
programming and then finally coming
around to being you know on exactly
heroes and she's even got shield
involvement at certain points and she's
got that ability to hop through
multiverses and that's gonna be a big
part of the MCU coming up so yeah I
wouldn't put it past them to totally put
that character into their universe if
they wanted to partly because the more
super heroines you can get in there
right now I think the better
and if they can share effectively Tom
Hollands spider-man I could totally see
them sharing spider-woman and that would
be a cool new I think it wouldn't be bad
necessarily to have maybe Sony develop
that and have her play in an animator Cu
and stuff like that because net gets
more flavors and more creators working
at this and you know she doesn't seem
like a pretty badass character to bring
in and you know spider-man we've done a
lot of Peter Parker and now we're
breaching the Miles Morales stuff I'm
chewing on this because it's really
relatable and of all the superheroes
spider-man is one of the most everyman
and so this to me is going back to a
more sort of heavy sci-fi but being
spider-man you know is the kind of
everyman superhero it does kind of sound
cool to me to see a spider person
scenario but any more nasty seedy
espionage type of way spy training and
black widow meets Superman
you know yeah I mean similar I have
Miles Morales has a couple of powers
that Peter Parker did not have she has a
few powers I are obviously like
spider-man but then there's a couple of
other things she can do as well my
favorite one of them being the
pheromones ability Oh with the fair B
act she's a lady lady in seduce that's
right
I secrete an awesome amount of pheromone
power as well as my men and women are
always falling at my feet
you guys might look at us through the
camera and be like wow John so sexy but
in person the woman and men are always
just like oh my god Craig you're so high
and that's because of my similar ability
jessica Giroux sparrowmon malware's i
have just as strong a pheromone powers
it smells like dog [ __ ] it works
don't worry about the scent itself but
it works that's the thing is like you
get past the initials the odor of it cuz
it actually smells you know sometimes
pheromones you can't smell them my
pheromones you really can they're very
tangible it's in the air yeah that's
like a Musk but there is magnetic
it is magnetic yeah truthfully your
pheromones are Megan yeah they really
are
they're electrifying you need you know
yeah she has like her superhuman hearing
and superhuman smell everything about
Spider Woman I associated with her
obviously smell hey man you know it's an
underrated superhero sense all right
superhuman smell and taste or underrate
on you man it's awesome and I believe
Miles released I remember in the video
game trailer he has a bed and blast
ability but yeah I mean III think the
idea of having her in here would be
totally awesome and you know
whoa culture might be ruining everything
it's like yeah we have Eddie Brock and
now we got Morbius and they've been
working on Kraven the hunter and we got
Miles Morales now and Peter Parker the
second you put a woman in there whoa
screams OH you should go back to the way
it was rely on the same few actors
playing all the superheroes no I think
this would be a great step but I do
think like they've had to do a lot of
rewriting already even within the old
Sony Pictures of Marvel's matter man
crap they even read it Venom's origin
because of all this stuff with deals and
contracts and rights and legalities blah
blah blah they had to change that within
their own spider-man universe you know
and with her backstory that intertwines
with Hydra shield Nick Fury all that
even with the Fantastic Four I believe
like she encounters Lygia masters along
the way
famously played by Kerry Washington the
weird thing with the spider-man universe
that they have going is all the
information we don't really know about
their deal with the MCU who that they
have to work yeah see what they got in
store man Spider Woman could work mmm
all right guys well what do you think
about Spider Woman being in this bunk
every time it's so good so good do you
want this or a Madame web movie more
Madame web hey everyone's opting for a
madam what how cool that Helen Mirren
madam women get a glass older lady in
there that was what I want to so I went
out of the box Jake that's what I want
man I'm right there with you John
subscribe to cosmic wonder if you
haven't done so already subscribe to the
real
Jax please click that notification Mele
get notified whenever we got a new
YouTube video up download and falls in
the Stardust app and of course Peyton
Niraj Krishnan
so recently while talking with Niraj he
sent me over some songs that I believe
are an Indian ooh I actually listened to
their four songs listened to three out
of four of them so far beautiful Tunes
they kind of remind me of like a mixture
of a whole bunch of classic rock I
didn't understand anything of what was
being said because it wasn't spoken to
my native tongue Japanese I didn't know
what was being said in there the whole
time
but I want to thank you for not just the
amount of support and contribution you
have given our way but you know for also
broadening my personal horizons and
tastes and music and I believe John
could dawn are you on that too we've got
some great taste in music you've
introduced me to the Church of the
cosmic skull among other things and
honestly this isn't related but I just
think that you should be the first
Indian spider-man because think about it
live in on the East Coast
glasses polite but maybe not the most
confident outgoing guy perfect dude to
save the city and also be blasting some
wonderful tunes so you got my vote Niraj
yeah well my buddy
yeah first spider-man to break out into
dance choreography second spider-man to
break out into first spider-man to have
an ensemble with him for the
choreography see if her eyes